Uh,
today we start,
guess what?
We start.
We start with Plato,
Plato's apology of Socrates.
Uh,
this is the best introductory text
to the study of political philosophy.
Why,
let me give you two reasons.
First,
it shows Socrates the,
a reputed founder of our discipline,
the founder of political science.
And I will say a little bit
more about that later on today.
Uh,
explaining himself and justifying himself
justifying his way of life before a
jury of his peers.
It shows Socrates speaking,
uh,
in a public forum defending the utility
of Philosophy for political life.
And secondly,
the apology demonstrates
also the vulnerability of
political philosophy in its
relation to the city in its
relation to political power.
You apology puts on trial not
merely a particular individual,
Socrates,
but puts on trial the very idea of
philosophy from its very beginnings
philosophy and the city philosophy and
political life have stood in a sort of
tension with,
with one another.
Socrates is charged as we will see by
the city for corrupting the youth in
impiety toward the gods.
Right?
In other words,
he's accused of treason,
high capital offense,
no other work of which I am aware helps
us better think through the conflict.
I would even say the necessary in end,
inevitable conflict between the freedom
of the mind and the requirements of
political life.
Are these two things,
are these two goods as it were,
freedom of mind and political life?
Are they compatible or are they
necessarily at odds with one another?
That seems to me to be a,
in some ways the fundamental question
that the apology asks us to consider.
Okay.
Now for generations,
uh,
the apology has stood out as a symbol
for the violation of free expression.
A,
it sets the,
the case for the individual committed
to the examined life over and against a
bigoted and prejudiced multitude.
The clearest statement of this view of,
again,
the individual set against the mob.
In some ways it's founded it very in a
work of a very famous civil libertarian
of the 19th century men named John Stuart
Mill in his famous tract called simply
I'm liberty mill road.
Mankind can hardly be too often reminded
that it was once a man named Socrates,
between whom and the legal authorities
of his time there took place.
A memorable collision
over and again,
and mill is kind of a famous case of
this over and against Socrates has been
described as a martyr for freedom
of speech and he has been somewhat
extravagantly compared at
various times to Jesus,
to Galileo,
to Sir Thomas Moore and has been used as
a role model for thinkers and political
activists from Henry
David Thoreau to Gandhi,
to Martin Luther King.
So Socrates has become a very central
might say symbol of political resistance
and political and resistance to,
to political power and of the dangers
to the individual of sort of unchecked a
rule.
But this reading of the apology,
as you might say,
a kind of brief for freedom of expression
in a warning against the dangers of
censorship and persecution.
Although this has been enormously
influential over the centuries,
at least over the last century and a half,
you have to ask yourself,
is this the reading that Plato intended?
Did Plato want us to read
the dialogue this way
as a teacher of mine use to say,
you read Plato your way.
I'll read him his way.
But uh,
how did,
how did Plato intend this
dialogue to be understood?
Note that Socrates never defends
himself by reference to the doctrine of
unlimited free speech.
He doesn't make that claim.
He doesn't make the claim about the
general utility of freedom or unlimited
speech.
Rather he maintains as he puts
it near the end of the dialogue,
uh,
end of the defense speech,
that the,
that the examined life is
alone worth living only those,
in other words,
engaged in the continuous struggle
to clarify their thinking,
to remove sources of
contradiction and incoherence.
Only those people can be said
to live worthwhile lives.
The unexamined life is not worth living.
Socrates confidently know,
defiantly say asserts to his listeners,
to his audience.
Nothing else matters for him.
His in other words seems to be
a highly personal in many ways,
highly individual quest for
self perfection and not a
doctrine about the value
of freedom of speech in general.
But even though you might say Socrates
seems to be engaged and again,
this highly personal
quest for self perfection,
there is something which one can't avoid.
Deeply political about the
apology and about his teaching.
At the heart of the dialogue are at
the heart of this speech rather is a
quarrel,
a quarrel with his
accusers over the question,
uh,
never stated directly perhaps,
but over the question of who has the
right to educate future citizens and
statesmen of the city of Athens.
Socrates is dispense speech like every
platonic dialogue is ultimately a
dialogue about education.
Who has the right to teach?
Who has the right to educate?
This is in many ways for Socrates the
fundamental political question of all
times.
It is the question of really who
governs or maybe put another way,
who should govern,
who,
who ought to govern.
Remember also that the city that brought
Socrates to trial was not just any
city.
It was a peculiar kind of city.
It was Athens and Athens was until only
fairly recent times in human history,
the most famous democracy
that ever existed.
I'd say fairly recent times until
you know the American democracy.
But it wasn't until at least
the 18th or 19th century,
the most famous democracy
that ever existed.
The speech of Socrates before the jury
is perhaps the most famous attempt to put
democracy itself on trial.
It is not merely Socrates
who was on trial.
Socrates intends to put the
democracy of Athens itself on trial.
Not only does the apology to,
for Socrates to defend
himself before the city,
before the city of Athens,
but Socrates puts the city of Athens on
trial and makes it defend itself before
the High Court of Philosophy.
So the ensuing debate within the dialogue
can be read as a struggle again over
who has title to rule?
Is it the people?
Is it the cart of Athens,
the De Moss,
to use the Greek word for the people?
Or is it Socrates,
the philosopher King,
who should be vested with
ultimate political authority?
That is of course,
the question that's taken
up in a very vivid way,
much more explicit way in the republic.
But it runs throughout the apology.
And you can't really,
uh,
understand the apology unless you see
that that is the question that Socrates is
posing throughout.
Yes.
With them.
Yeah.
Good.
Okay.
So
it's in names put on the board and some
dates just because I wanted to talk a
little bit about the political
context of this dialogue.
One can of course read,
there's nothing wrong
with reading the apology.
Again,
it's the kind of enduring
symbol of the plight of the a.
You might say the just individual,
uh,
confronted with an unjust mob
or an unjust political rule,
uh,
is again a question that Plato
takes up in the apology when,
uh,
we will see in the republic,
excuse me,
when a character in the book
named Glaucon who happens to be,
as it were,
the brother of Plato ask Socrates if it
is actually better to be just or simply
to have the reputation for justice.
And Socrates Rep says it is better
to be just even if that results in
persecution and death.
But the trial is not,
again,
just an enduring symbol of
justice versus injustice.
It is an actual historical event that
takes place in a particular moment of
political time.
And this bears,
I think decisively on how we
come to understand the case,
both for and against Socrates.
Let me talk a little
bit about that context.
Okay.
The trial of Socrates takes place in the
year three 99 and all of these refer to
know before the common era three 99.
Some of you will know that,
that try this try that trial follows
very quickly upon the heels of the Pella,
the famous Peloponnesian war.
This was the war related by Socrates
is slightly older contemporary,
a man named through acidities who wrote
the history of the Peloponnesian war,
the war that took place between the
two great powers of the Greek world,
between the Spartans and the and their
allies and Athens and its allies.
Uh,
the Athens,
the Athens that fought this war against
Sparta was in Athens at the height of
its political power and prestige under
the leadership of its first citizen
Paraclese whose name is is also up there
at the very top under paraclese Athens
had built the famous Acropolis.
Uh,
it had established Athens as a
mighty and redoubtable naval power.
And it created an unprecedented
level of artistic and cultural life,
even today known simply
as para Cleon Athens.
But Athens was also something
completely unprecedented in the world.
It was a democracy.
And again,
even today,
the expression Athenian democracy connotes
an ideal of the most complete form of
democratic government
that has ever existed.
We are the school of helpless.
This is what [inaudible] boasts to his
listeners in the famous funeral oration,
uh,
told by through acidities,
we throw our city open to the world
and never exclude foreigners from any
opportunity of learning and observing,
even though the eyes of an enemy may
profit from our liberality paraclese
boasts.
Once again,
the question maybe you
want to ask about this is
how could the world's first freest and
most open society sentenced to death?
A man who spoke freely
about his own ignorance and
professed to care for nothing
so much as virtue and human excellence.
Now,
at the outbreak of the Peloponnesian war,
Socrates was just under 40 years of age.
And we learned from the speech
that Socrates was himself.
Uh,
serve in the military and served
in defense of his country.
The war,
uh,
the Peloponnesian war was fought,
as you can see,
a over considerable length of time on
and off for almost a period of 30 years.
And it was concluded in the year four,
all four with the defeat of Athens and
the installing of a pro spartan oligarchy
as pro spartan regime known as simply as
the 30 tyrants also out there who ruled
Athens for a year.
Uh,
the next year,
four oh three,
the tyrants,
the 30,
as they were called,
were driven out and a democracy,
a democratic government was once
again reestablished in Athens.
Just three years later,
uh,
three men named Anna
[inaudible] Mellitus and Lycos,
uh,
all of whom had been part of their
democratic resistance movement against the
Spartan Oligarchy.
These men brought
charges against Socrates.
Their charges against him were corrupting
the young and disbelieving in the gods
that the city believes in.
So you can see that the charges were
brought by people who were themselves.
Again,
part of the Democratic
Resistance Movement,
uh,
and Eh and eh,
the names of antiques and
Mellitus is you've read,
you know,
appear in the,
in,
in the dial in,
in the speech itself.
So the charges brought against Socrates
did not simply grow out of thin air.
Maybe we should rephrase the question,
not why did the Athenians
bring Socrates to trial,
but why did they permit him to carry on
his practice of challenging the law and
the authority of the law
for as long as they did?
Okay.
Add to this,
the fact that when the sock,
when Socrates was brought to trial again,
the democracy had only
recently been reestablished,
but that many friends and former students
of Socrates had been in themselves
implicated in the rule of the 30.
The hated 30 tyrants among the members
of the 30 were a man named courteous,
is actually a platonic
dialogue named after him,
a man named Critias who
was a relative of Plato's.
And another man named comedies also name
is the title of a platonic dialogue.
Comedies,
who was Plato's Uncle
Plato himself.
Uh,
he tells us much later in life.
And his famous seventh letter,
Plato himself was invited by his
relatives to help to form a part of the
government of the 30 and later Plato said,
ah,
that's so abhorrent.
Did they become that they made the older
democracy look like the golden age?
So the point I'm suggesting is that many
of Socrates's students and associates,
including Plato himself,
had some connection
with this oligarchical,
uh,
government that had ruled,
Athens,
uh,
for a brief time.
And Socrates was himself
not above suspicion.
You often don't we,
even today,
yes,
we often judge teachers by their students,
by the company they keep,
yes.
Don't worry.
No one is above suspicion.
Socrates himself had been a close
associate of a man named El Sobriety's.
Uh,
probably the most prominent Athenian
and the generation after Paraclese,
uh,
Elsa by cities was the man
who engineered a disastrous,
a Sicilian expedition,
uh,
and later ended his life as a defector,
going to Sparta.
Uh,
his complex relationship with Socrates is,
by the way,
recounted in the drunken speech that Al
Sobriety's gives in Plato's dialogues
symposium.
So you can see that the trial of Socrates,
the little speech that you have read
takes place in the shadow of military
defeat,
of resistance,
of conspiracy and betrayal.
Okay.
Socrates was 70 years old
at the time of the trial.
So this was a highly charged
political environment,
uh,
far more volatile than,
for example,
uh,
the kind of partisan quarrels
we see today in our republic.
I hope.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let me talk about the accusations.
Let me move from the political context
of the speech to the accusations.
And I say accusations because they are,
there are,
as you read,
if you read closely,
you will see there were actually two
sets of accusations leveled against
Socrates early in the speech.
Socrates claims that his current
accusers annotates and Mellitus,
uh,
again,
the democratic resistance fighters,
uh,
have brought charges against the charges
they have brought against him are
themselves,
the descendants of an earlier generation
of accusers who were responsible for he
claims maligning and creating an
unfavorable prejudice against Socrates.
Okay.
These charges are not new.
He tells the jury and
many members of the jury,
he says,
well,
if had a fee and unf we'll have had
formed an unfavorable opinion about him.
This was the day before.
They were intense forms of jury
selection where they would ask people,
do you have a view of the case?
Many of the jurors would have known
Socrates or certainly would have heard of
him,
uh,
and he says would have had already an
unfavorable opinion formed about him by
this earlier generation
of accusers referenced.
He makes to a comic poet.
Yes.
A comic poet and unequivocal reference
to the playwright Aristophanes whose,
whose name,
uh,
I've had put up on the board.
Aristophanes is the one who created
the original or the initial prejudice
against Socrates.
What was that prejudice that sa,
that aristophanes's comic poet had created
the illusion to Aristophanes and the
comic poet
is a part of what Plato calls
in Book 10 of the Republic.
The old quarrel between
philosophy and poetry.
This call is as staple
of Plato's dialogues.
What is a central theme,
not only of the symposium
in which Aristotle and
Socrates are actually shown at
the same dinner table with one another.
Uh,
but it is also a key
feature of the republic,
which we will be reading in a week where
Socrates offers in elaborate proposal
for the censorship and control of poetry
if it is to be made compatible with the
demands of political justice.
In fact,
in a way you cannot understand the
republic unless you understand the poetic
backdrop to it.
And Socrates is longstanding
engagement with the poetic tradition.
Okay?
And this back and forth between himself
and the man he calls this comic poet the
core,
the core of this quarrel between
the philosopher and the poet,
between Socrates and Aristotle and A's.
It's not just an aesthetic,
uh,
judgment or it is not
simply an aesthetic coral.
It is,
again,
deeply political or at least has
something very political about it.
It gets to the essence of the question
of who is best equipped to educate future
generations of citizens.
And civic leaders are the
philosophers or are the poets,
uh,
you might say the true legislators for
mankind if you want to use Shelley's
favorite Shelley's dictum.
Okay.
Which one?
Legislates for mankind
at the time of Socrates,
the Greeks already had a century's long
tradition of poetic education going back
centuries to the time of homer and
Hesiod that set out certain x and clary
models of heroic virtue and civic life.
The Homeric epics were to the Greek world.
What the Bible is to our world.
That is to say in some respects,
the ultimate authority
regarding the way of the gods,
the relation to the world and the type
of virtues appropriate to human beings.
The virtues endorsed by the poetic
tradition of which aristophanes's is the
great representative here,
the great inheritor,
and represent the virtues of this
tradition with the virtues of a warrior
culture of a people at warlike
peoples and men at war.
These were the qualities that had
guided the Greeks for centuries and
contributed to their rise to power.
It contributed to Athens as well as
Sparta's rise to greatness from a small
dispersed people to a great world.
Power and again,
allow them to achieve a level of artistic,
intellectual and political accomplishment.
Akin to Renaissance Florence,
uh,
Elizabethan England and,
dirt is Weimar.
So what does it cost?
What is at stake in this quarrel between
Socrates and the poets between Socrates
in the poetic tradition
that he alludes to it?
First,
Socrates manner of teaching is
markedly different from the poets,
right?
Does anyone know here the opening
line of the Iliad home resilient?
Does anyone know the first line?
Want to remember that from high school?
What?
Right?
But I mean same goddess,
the wrath of Achilles.
Alright.
Uh,
sing goddess.
The wrath of Achilles.
The poet are irregular,
right?
They call on gods and goddesses
to inspire them with song,
to fill them with inspiration,
to tell stories of people with superhuman
strength and courage and anger.
Okay?
By contrast,
you could say the method of
Socrates is not a rat killer.
It is not storytelling.
It is conversational.
It is argumentative.
If you want to use the
word he applies to it.
It is dialectical.
Socrates makes arguments and he wants
others to engage with him to discover
which argument can best withstand the
test of rational scrutiny and debate.
There are no arguments in Homer's
Iliad or artists that you,
you hear stories,
you hear strong and compelling stories,
no arguments.
Socrates makes,
in other words,
continual questioning and not the
telling of stories and the recitation of
versus the essence of this
new political education.
He questions the methods
of teaching of the poet,
but secondly,
again,
homer and the poets sing the virtues.
Men at war.
Socrates wants to replace the warrior
citizen with a new kind of citizen,
a whole new set you might say,
of citizen virtues,
the new Socratic citizen,
let's call him that for a moment.
The new Socratic citizen may have some
features in common with the older Homeric
warrior,
but Socrates ultimately wants to replace
military combat with a new kind of,
you might take call it verbal facility,
verbal combat in which the,
again,
the person with the best argument
is declared to be victorious.
The person with the best argument,
let the best argument prevail.
The famed Socratic method of argumentation
is basically all that remains of the
older,
uh,
pre Socratic culture
of struggle and combat.
The Socratic set up.
The new Socratic citizen is to be trained
in the art of argument in dialectic.
And we will talk a little
later about what that means.
So
it is as a challenge or is a challenger
to the poets and all they stand for with
century long tradition of poetic education
that Socrates asserts himself that
Socrates presents himself.
The apologies show Socrates as
offering a new model of citizenship.
A new kind of citizen
is challenge to the poets,
is in a way the basis for the resentment
that has built up against him and that
aristophanes's and what he calls
the earlier accusers have brought,
brought to bear.
In fact,
you might take so seriously was Socrates
taken by Aristophanes and the poets
that aristophanes's
devoted an entire play.
He wrote an entire play about
Socrates called the clouds,
the clouds,
right devoted to debunking in ridicule.
Socrates is profession of
learning Aristophanes play.
Sometimes it's even included in
certain additions of the book.
You're reading like this one.
It has the,
uh,
addition of the
aristophanes's clouds in it,
along with the apology and Credo.
The existence of that pledge shows to
all of us just how seriously Socrates was
taken by the greatest
of his contemporaries.
And aristophanes's was
along with Sophocles.
And you rip Adiz and others
among the greatest of the,
of the Greek playwrights,
the mockery you might say of Socrates
remains one of the sincerest form of
flattery.
They took him very seriously.
Okay,
let me just say something
about the clouds.
This comic play,
this satire on,
on Socrates because it is part
of that initial accusation.
It's awkward,
he says is,
is leveled against him.
Here Aristophanes presents
Socrates as an investigator,
and this is part of the first charge.
Remember,
an investigator of the things,
a loft in the things under the earth
and who makes the weaker argument the
stronger.
That's the argument that,
uh,
Socrates,
says Aristophanes brought about,
brings against him.
In this play,
Socrates is presented as the head,
uh,
the leader,
the director,
uh,
what we might think of is the
first think tank in human hitting,
known to human history.
Uh,
it's called in the play itself,
the front hysteria,
which means there is sometimes translated
as the thinkery or the think a tear.
The think materia or simply a
kind of think tank where fathers,
Athenian fathers bring their sons to
be indoctrinated into the mysteries of
Socratic wisdom.
And in the play,
Socrates is shown hovering,
flying above the stage in a basket in
order better to be able to observe the
clouds that the things a lot,
right.
But also in many ways symbolizing
Socrates is at least on the air staff.
And he's a con.
Socrates is detachment from
the things down here on earth.
The thing that concern his
fellow citizens Socrates's,
uh,
Socrates is a kind of a,
what in German people
will call a Lyft match.
She's a man up in the air,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
he's,
he's so detached.
He's,
he,
he doesn't have his feet on the ground.
And a Socrates is shown not only
mocking the gods in doing this,
but he is shown by Aristophanes to teach
incest and to teach all of the things
that violate every decent human,
you know,
taboo in Sas,
the,
the beating of one's parents,
all these kinds of things.
Socrates is shown,
Socrates is presented as a
kind of corrosive skepticism,
which,
uh,
is it the core of his chief of staff
of Aristophanes charge against him.
To make a long story short,
uh,
the play concludes with Socrates.
His think tank being
burned to the ground by,
uh,
just ground whole disciple,
an object lesson for all later.
Professors,
I would say teach teaching nonsense,
right?
Yeah.
Don't get any ideas
dick.
A match to the department.
Yeah.
So how accurate is that
picture of Socrates,
the man who investigates the things
aloft and the things under the ground?
The clouds was written in for 23
when Socrates was in his mid forties.
And the error Stefanik
Socrates is essentially a,
we call a natural philosopher,
again,
investigating the things,
a loft under the ground.
He is what we would call today,
a scientist and natural scientist.
But this seems quite removed,
doesn't it from the Socrates who was
brought up on charges of corrupting the
young and impiety in,
in the apology.
And here is where Socrates tells
actually here is where Socrates,
he actually tells a story
very important in the,
in the course of this speech,
he provides a kind of
intellectual biography of an
incident that occurred long
before the trial and set him
on a very different path.
He recalls the story dot.
Don't you remember,
uh,
of a man named Carafano and a friend of
his who had gone to the Delphic oracle
who had gone to the Oracle Adelphi
and ask if there was anyone wiser than
Socrates and was told there was not.
Socrates real tells us that when he
was told us he express disbelief in the
Oracle,
he didn't believe it.
And in order to disprove
the Oracle statement,
he says he began a lifelong quest
to find someone wiser than himself.
A quest that in the course of which
led him to interrogate the politicians,
the poets,
the craftsmen,
all people of reputed to be knowledgeable
and his conversations led him to ask
questions.
Not About,
as we were saying,
natural scientific phenomenon,
but questions about the virtues as he
tells us the virtues of a human being and
a citizen,
what we would call today,
perhaps moral and political questions.
That incident,
uh,
that Socrates tells here is,
represents what one could
call the famous Socratic turn.
Socrates is second sailing,
so to speak.
Uh,
it represents the moment in the life of
Socrates where he turns away from the
investigation of natural phenomenon to
the study of the human and political
things,
the moral and political things,
the Delphic Oracle,
the Delphic story for what it's worth
marks a major turning point in Socrates is
intellectual biography.
The move from the younger Eric,
we could call an heiress to phonics,
Socrates,
the Socrates,
who again investigates the things
a loft and under the earth,
uh,
to the later platonic,
what we could call platonic Socrates,
the founder of political science,
Socrates,
the founder of our discipline who asks
about the virtues of moral and political
life.
Socrates account of this turn,
this major turn in his life and career
leaves a lot of questions on answered
that may be even occurred to you
as you were reading this dialogue,
reading this speech.
Why does he turn away from
the investigation of natural
phenomenon to the study
of human and political things?
Yeah.
The Delphic oracle is interpreted by
Socrates at least to command engaging with
other others in
philosophical conversation.
Why does he interpret it this way?
Why does this same,
the proper interpretation to engage
in these kinds of conversations?
Uh,
it is this Socrates who was brought up
on charges of corruption and impiety,
and yet none of this quite
answers the question,
what is the nature of Socrates is crime?
What did he do?
What did corruption and impiety mean?
Uh,
to try to answer those questions,
we would have to look a little bit at
what Socrates means or what is meant by
this new kind of Socratic citizen.
Who is this citizen?
Okay.
The charges brought
against Socrates by Anna,
just in melodies we see are not the same
exactly as those brought against him by
Aristophanes the comic poet
and it just in Mellitus.
Talk about impiety in corruption,
not investigating the things aloft and
making the weaker argument is stronger.
What do these terms mean?
Impiety and corruption?
In what sense are these civic offenses?
What,
what,
what could impiety have meant to
his audience and his contemporary?
At a minimum,
we would think the charge of impiety
suggest disrespect of the gods.
Impiety need not be the
same thing as atheism,
although mellitus confuses the two.
Uh,
but it does suggest your reverence,
even blasphemy toward the things that
a society cares most deeply about.
Yes.
To be mps is to disrespect those things.
A person or a society cares most deeply
about when people today for refer to
flag burning as a desecration
desecrating the flag,
they were speaking the
language of impiety,
right?
They are speaking the language of some
kind of religious or crazy religious
desecration.
Melitis whose name in Greek actually
means care accuses Socrates of not caring
properly for the things that
his fellow citizens care about.
So the question is what
does Socrates care about?
What,
what does he care about?
Consider the following.
Every society,
uh,
which we know operates within the
medium of belief or faith of some kind.
Take our founding documents,
the declaration of independence,
the constitution,
all men are created equal.
That we are endowed
with inalienable rights,
that all government,
legitimate government grows
out of consent and the like
these beliefs farm something
like a kind of national creed,
you might say American national creed,
what it means to be an American and not
someone else get how many people could
give a kind of reasoned account
of what makes these beliefs true?
What grounds these beliefs?
Most of us,
most of the time hold these
beliefs as a matter of faith.
As a matter of belief,
uh,
we have learned about the,
because we have learned about them from
childhood because they were written by
Thomas Jefferson or some other,
a reputed high authority to question
those beliefs would seem to exhibit a kind
of lack of civic faith,
faith in our ruling opinions.
In short,
you might say a lack of
civic piety or respect.
Socrates clearly believes that piety or
faith is the natural condition of the
citizen.
Every society no matter of what kind
requires a kind of faith in its ruling
principles and its fundamental beliefs.
But belief seems to be threatened
from at least two sources.
One is simple disbelief or unbelief.
Uh,
kind of just sort of rejection of a ruling
opinion simply because you don't like
it of some kind.
You know,
when you see the bumper sticker
on the car question authority,
just kind of rejection of,
of,
of ruling opinion.
But the other source of conflict with
ruling opinion is from philosophy.
Philosophy is not the same thing
as simple disbelief or rejection.
But the two can be easily confused.
Philosophy grows out of a desire
to replace opinion with knowledge,
opinion,
or belief with reason for philosophy.
It is not enough simply
to hold a belief on faith,
but one must be able to
give a rational account,
a reasoned account for one's belief.
It's goal again is to replace civic faith
with rational knowledge and therefore
philosophy is necessarily at odds with
beliefs and with this kind of civic
faith,
the citizen may accept certain beliefs
on faith because he or she is attached to
a particular kind of
political order or regime.
But for the philosopher,
this is never enough for the philosophers
seeks to judge those beliefs in the,
in the light of true standards and the
light of what is always and everywhere.
True is a quest for knowledge.
There was unnecessary in in an inevitable
tension between philosophy and belief
or to put it another way
between philosophy and the
civic pieties that holds the
city together.
Okay.
From this point of view,
I want to say Socrates,
where we could ask what Socrates
guilty of impiety on the face of it.
The answer it had that seems yes,
Socrates does not care about the same
thing his fellow citizens care about his
opening words to the jewelry scene to
convey this I he says him simply foreign
to the manner of speech here.
This seems to be a statement of his
alien nation or disaffection from the
concerns of his fellow Athenians.
I know nothing about what you
do or what you care about yet.
It certainly doesn't seem right to say
that Socrates does not care at all.
He,
he claims to care deeply,
perhaps in more deeply than anyone has
ever cared around him before or since in
among the things he cares deeply about.
He says,
is this calling to do nothing as he says,
to do nothing but persuade
you both younger and older,
not to care for bodies and money,
but how your soul will be in
the best possible condition.
That concern with the state of one soul,
he tells the jury has led him
not only to impoverish himself,
but to turn himself away
from the public business,
from the things that concern the city
to the pursuit of private virtue.
And here are the words of his that I
want to leave you with today from section
31 d of the apology.
It's awkward.
He's right.
This is what opposes my political activity
and its opposition seems to me to be
altogether noble for no well,
men of Athens,
if I had long ago attempted
to be politically active,
I would long ago have perished
and I would have benefited.
Neither you nor myself.
No.
Do not be vexed with me when I speak.
The truth for there is no human being who
will preserve his life if he genuinely
opposes either you or any other multitude
and prevents many unjust and unlawful
things from happening in the city.
Rather,
he says,
if someone who really fights for justice
is going to preserve himself even for a
short time,
it is necessary for him to leave a pride
to lead a private rather than a public
life.
Think about that.
If someone who really fights for
justice is going to preserve himself,
it is necessary for him to lead a private,
not a public life.
How are we to understand Socrates's pursue
his claim that the pursuit of justice
requires him to turn away
from public to private life?
What is this new kind of citizen again,
concerned with this
kind of private virtue,
this concern for the virtue of one soul?
That's the question I
want us to consider again,
uh,
for next week as we finish the apology
and move our way up to the cryto.
Okay.
We'll do that for next week.